you guys are looking for garyvee journal
emissions right here VIP I'm looking for
over there we're not letting people in
it as good as I've been blog gonna shoe
launch my boys like the sunshine and Los
Angeles real good iris or it's
unbelievable we'd much rather eat soil
than smelling roses that's why we have
so many roses these are just good human
beings bird overslept so now I got to go
on in lemon 15 solo when impact is your
motivation you could be calm
I like the people waiting in line trying
to make that money
no this reminds me of its baseball card
shows Saul it is it's just patience man
they [ __ ] hard-ass work listening to
absolutely nobody and everybody wants to
listen to other people's opinion since
all [ __ ] mistakes you know you have
one big thing they don't have it's one
[ __ ] persons in there I'm gonna [ __ ]
bring it as hard in that [ __ ] can this
is a serious [ __ ] event but people
are going to realize really matters in
college so [ __ ] call their bluff I
work at Burger King
live with nine foot like life's about
options bro who knows maybe thirty four
thousand dollars here at 26 you're not
gonna [ __ ] make me saw this guy this
is just natural talent this was natural
talent for all the rest of us we've got
a [ __ ] bride we're not all
we're being I was too scared that you
were going to get it first
you're just making business decisions if
you can't afford [ __ ] future you
can't afford future right no this is the
sleeper window get to the sneaker window
[Music]
you got to do what the [ __ ] you want to
do 99 percent of influencers go for the
catch never waver almost everybody wants
it faster and most of the people here
aren't where they're at because they did
actions that were predicated on lack of
patience hot ones community I love you
even the 7,000 of you that said I'm the
worst piece of [ __ ] that's why I replied
to you because I got love for you did
you can you throw that photos around
take a far should never imagine what you
and I do for a living being an
entrepreneur we cross over to what he
does for a living
you're not stopping
my pastor to Miami thank you so much I
appreciate the love it
hey keep doing your thing
post-production I don't like dialing
back the questions too happy with this
way to never buy the Porsche company is
to buy a Porsche
your thing man fun to watch
I appreciate that such good vibes so
that were you is my sneaker yeah first
entrepreneur collaboration and Z popped
for like a boss never do something for
somebody else be new period and a story
because I mean any more good way to make
the next year
gosh my man
and he rocket this guy's involved for
this whole global thing like that idea
it just goes so good like what the [ __ ]
do we have to complete the wine guys are
here these guys
I made this for you Gary it's a piece I
called flip challenge I was a big fan of
your [ __ ] curly champion right here
you don't know get on who this man is
[Music]
this is [ __ ] legit drinking brother I
need to exercise tomorrow everybody
here's making bad decisions oh that's
gonna kill
everybody walking around here has never
been punched in the face they're still
vulnerable right imagine that should
happen us 37 Eric Moose he's my favorite
from everybody we are one bowl of
yo [ __ ] software in the [ __ ] dome
not your phone that's your [ __ ] phone
but get it one light most locations
practicality
right now working if you're willing to
bleed if you will be humble you wore get
work you know Riku your operating system
and the Dutch and the dome not the phone
you either have money for you have time
fancy doesn't want to [ __ ] deal 100
people is at 5:30 5:30 second floor
studio 530 the complex studio it's going
down the Q&A session come see me if you
were at complex all that so please open
the up wrestling promotion [ __ ] watching
thing through I'll tell you right now
there's not one [ __ ] group here that
have the right concept they just kept
iterating but they did they did it thank
you brother thank you hey Chris sighs
new project do not sleep on it
it's all the same [ __ ] self-awareness
whether you could at patience gratitude
hard work it's just beginning
you're not about it you're not even in
the parking lot yet to the [ __ ] game
to the national anthem like you just
start I'm eating lunch with the scalpers
you're not gonna know how it would have
worked out anyway stop [ __ ] and
start doing something now get your
[ __ ] mental fit she's got one [ __ ]
life
stop [ __ ] I might be in Atlanta the
day after Thanksgiving you'll never
regret [ __ ] and making that punch so
much progress with both of us yeah
not even here I know I'm late Billy Bob
Thank You Barney you're unbelievable for
seeing it for reaching out
I just want to be better than I was the
year before as a person as a as an
executor as an entrepreneur as a
personality as a dad just better to tell
the people they're gonna die oh I know
they're gonna die it's what they're
gonna do about it
do something you can't make up now
either you played you know spades and
CeeLo or you did it either you like
lived in the environment we lived in or
use in it nobody seemed to [ __ ] about a
supreme backpack when your help isn't
going anywhere
thank you guys so much I have nothing
but love for you yeah oh yeah that is
you this vlog double fisted double fist
it on the blog it's good day guys today
pretty good right we hacked a little
culture we hacked a little culture today
I was in a different headspace in there
oh what was David I said was a 9:00 to
11:00 entrepreneur's
I was a good content